Lowood is america's most prolific
inventor now he's the first guy to
overtake Thomas Edison as having the
most patents on file with the US Patent
Office and he's this guy that you
probably never even heard of he's an
expert in astrophysics in chemistry and
biology in paleontology you name it
Lowell knows something about it and so
the scope of his inventions is insane
he's working on nuclear reactors he's
working on vaccines he's working on ways
to deliver drugs to people he comes up
with silly stuff like a laser shaver for
about 30 or 40 years he worked for the
government designing weapons and space
systems in a lot of ways he's probably
most famous for the Star Wars project
inventing the space lasers that were
meant to kind of protect us from the
Russians during the Cold War in about
2006 his life took this really abrupt
turn he went to work for this company
called intellectual Ventures which is
famous for patenting ideas one of the
things that they're famous for is these
inventions sessions the people that
Lowell tends to hang out with during
these sessions are Bill Gates and Nathan
Myhrvold who used to be the chief
technology officer of Microsoft and who
now runs intellectual Ventures and so
you get these these guys with these huge
brains and they just sit around for
three or four hours and bat ideas back
and forth the relationship between Bill
Gates and Lowell started only about
eight or nine years ago and they since
become sort of these like put somebodies
it really feels like they're they all
maybe the only two people on earth who
can talk about some of these things at
the same level so Lowell is he's quite
the character he likes to stay to
himself he doesn't like attention even
though there's a couple photos that
exist of him out there he refuses to
take any more photos he's 74 he's got
this very dark red hair and there's this
bushy beard he looks almost like Santa
Claus he goes into these tangents when
he's talking but always seems to
actually end up answering your question
and he describes the inventive process
more as just him recalling these facts
that are floating around in his head and
he sort of has this ability to arrange
them in different ways
it's just this recall from all these
different fields the thing that struck
me about here is I don't really think
he's good or bad he's just this guy who
is compelled to solve problems and
invent new ideas